hallo zusammen bis einschließlich Montag
hörte ich ja noch das Osterspezial die
großen Tatort deutschland-dokus die sind
noch aus der Zeit bevor wir auf die
täglichen Folgen umgestellt haben das
heißt heute nimmt euch Sky du mal mit
durch den Fall des schneekönigs und an
dieser Stelle ein kleiner Transparenz
Hinweis der Schneekönig ist Anfang
November 2022 gestorben die Folge wurde
aber knapp ein Jahr vor seinem Tod
veröffentlicht wisst ihr bescheid und
jetzt geht's los
eigentlich alles mögliche erlebt und es
geht alle ich kann es nicht mehr toppen
Hamburg im Sommer 2020 das ist die
Stimme von ronaldining sie gehört zu
einem stiernackigen Hünen dessen kurz
geraspeltes weißes Haar einen mächtigen
Schädel bedeckt aus dem helle und sehe
sehr sehr schlauer Augen heraus Blitzen
seine kräftigen Arme hatte vor dem weit
geöffnetem Hemd und dem mächtigen Bauch
verschränkt ja wer ist dieser Mann mit
Boxer Nase und dem verschmitzten Lachen
vielleicht fällt ja bei einigen der
Groschen wenn man seinen Szenen Namen
hört hier sitzt munter und laut wie
immer Luggy man findet die König und ich
war Koka in Deutschland viele sagen groß
ich sage eigentlich normal
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
Ronald blakimi der Schneekönig von
Hamburg
Ronald mieling wird am 12 juli 1950 in
Hamburg geboren die 70 Jahre sieht man
ihm kaum an gut gehalten würde man sagen
aber vielleicht hatte dieser Mann
schlichtweg keine Zeit zum Altern dafür
bietet das Leben einfach zu viel ich
habe auch jetzt ein Alter erreicht wo
ich ruhiger geworden bin meiner
terrarienkissen runtergegangen ich bin
jetzt seit vier Jahren aus dem Knast ich
habe in Hamburg versucht nach meiner
Entlassung eine Wohnung zu bekommen gab
es nicht nur blockiert da habe ich
gemerkt dass die Polizei irgendwie
beschattet macht tut den habe ich
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal auf die
Füße getreten den einen oder anderen und
diese Nacht tragend und habe gedacht da
geht's nach Bremen oh ja den hatte auf
die Füße getreten sie behalten ihn im
Auge aus Gründen wie wir noch
hinreichende fahren werden dabei hat er
in der eigenen Familie sogar
Gesetzeshüter denn sein Vater max ist
Polizist seine Mutter else ist Hausfrau
1959 kommt Ronalds Bruder Ralf zur Welt
die Kinder wachsen behütet in einem
Mehrfamilienhaus im Stadtteil Barmbek
auf die Eltern versuchen ihnen alles zu
ermöglichen eigentlich beste
Voraussetzungen für ein gradliniges
Leben so schildert es jedenfalls die
2008 verstorbene else meelin in einem
Interview von 2002 ich habe meine Kinder
das so schön gemacht ich habe mir
Führerschein gemacht
nach der Ostsee
und bei mir kann mein Kind ja nicht
bieten Luft und gutes Essen und Liebe
alles war da und auch bleibt die schaut
gern zurück zu seinen Jugendjahren aber
damals begann sich etwas in dem jungen
sportlichen Mann zu reden der Vater
später 1984 an Krebs gestorben ahnte
sicher schon Mitte der 70er dass sein
Sohn andere Vorstellungen vom Leben
hatte
also meine Kindheit war sehr glücklich
meine Mutter war zwar eine Glucke und
mein Vater war eigentlich der war der
coole eigentlich der hat immer gesagt
guck mal wenn du irgendwas machst aber
immer ja Polizist wenn du irgendwas
macht dann lass dich nicht erwischen und
ansonsten gehst dann knapp
ja der behütete Familienalltag enkt den
jungen Ronald mieling ein er wird raus
aus Hamburg Barmbek das konservative
Leben hinter sich lassen was erleben
nicht im Mittelklasse Wohlstands Mief
ersticken
ich bin aufgewachsen in einer Straße da
haben praktisch nur
Polizisten
gefängnisleute also jetzt Bedienstete
überall waren wann die
staatsbeschäftigte und wenn ich dann in
den 50er Jahren gesehen habe wenn die am
Sonntag dann ihre Autos geputzt haben
und zu dieser Gelsenkirchener Barock der
herrscht hat und dieses äh in meine Frau
hat einen Pelzmantel deine hat noch
keinen mein Auto ist größeren das ist
mir so auf den Senkel gegangen das ist
nicht dein Leben so und irgendwann hat
sich das so ergeben und habe gesagt
Kriminalität hat irgendwo ein reizt so
und dann habe ich das auch gemacht
eine konkrete Entscheidung die aber noch
Zeit brauchte um Wirklichkeit zu werden
erst einmal führt Blacky ein normales
Teenager Leben mit Moped Mädchen Sport
und Feiern er sieht gut aus und findet
schnell Anschluss
einer der mealing besonders gut kennt
ist Wolfgang Gier sie sind damals 15
Jahre alt als er und Ronald sich 1965
kennenlernen Wolfgang ist schon damals
Kampfsport begeistert und gilt noch
heute in Deutschland als Pionier der
kickbox-szene sie werden beste Freunde
Wolfgang gibt ihm den Spitznamen Blacky
wegen seiner vollen schwarzen Haare auf
alten Fotos sieht man Ronald Mehling im
Judoanzug beim Training posieren die
langen gewählten Haare wild abstehend
und dazu noch einen flaumigen pubertären
Schnauzer im teenagergesicht
[Musik]
Wolfgang Gier blättert in einem alten
Fotoalbum und erinnert sich
sympathischer Typ
irgendwie das dass sie die Chemie stimmt
gleich also bei uns beiden wir haben
viel zusammen gemacht
und ja
das war einfach schön die Fotos zeigen
die Jugendlichen früher hätte man sie
vermutlich eher Halbstarken Truppe
genannt in Verkleidungen als Bankräuber
oder in langer Unterwäsche einfach so
als Jungs
fotografiert
das weiß ich noch
S-Bahn gefahren
die Kumpels Wolfgang und Ronald sind
harte Hunde und Fotos beweisen sie
treiben ihren Sport wo und wann immer es
geht dann wenn wir draußen im Winter
trainiert
da sind natürlich die Füße festgefroren
am Boden nur leider habe ich nicht mehr
die vier Jahre waren schon intensiv
Blacky wird zum Draufgänger er bricht
gern die Regeln fährt zu schnell
Motorrad schiebt sich in den Vordergrund
und hat eine große Klappe er jobt hier
und da mit 18 Jahren
1968 begeht er seine erste Straftat
schwerer Raum die Tat stellt auch die
Freundschaft zu Freund Wolfgang Gier auf
einer harte Probe das erste mal vier
Wochen schädlerstraße
am Stall also dieses schon heftig das
sollte die Jugendlichen abschrecken
irgendwas zu machen und da ist das denn
jeden dritten Tag gab es eine trocken
Brot da musste die Matratze rausgepackt
werden da gab es ein Holzbrett und so da
war nur eine Stunde freigegang im Kreis
und man durfte sich mit keinem
unterhalten und als er da raus kam der
hat man schon so gemerkt dass er gedacht
hat so ich bin jetzt irgendwie der der
der oberverbrecher oder so und dann aber
nachher wo er das mit dem Schlachter
gemacht hatte
da war ja schon die Zeit mit vorher
schon dass er das doch schon erzählt hat
nicht direkt Einzelheiten aber das vor
und dies und das
[Musik]
am ersten Mai 1978 wird der Hamburger
fleischgroßhändler Manfred Hering Tod in
seinem Haus im niedersächsischen
Rheindorf aufgefunden der 45-Jährige
erfolgreiche Unternehmer wird bei einem
vermuteten Raubüberfall von mehreren
Kugeln aus nächster Nähe im Kopf und
Bauch getroffen die Tatwaffe ein
us-karabiner 30 m2 die Verdächtigen sind
noch flüchtig
gesucht wird nach einem Betonbauer und
einem Koch es sind Ronald Mehling und
sein Freund Jens weh als sie den
Unternehmer ausrauben wollen lösen sich
die tödlichen Schüsse aus der alten
weltkriegswaffe
das Grinsen auf Mehrings zerfeuchten
Gesicht verschwindet für einen Moment
und die Augen hören auf zu blitzen
das beruhigt wirklich und das ist äh das
ist eigentlich das schwarze Fleck auf
meiner Seele ich beruhigen sonst gar
nichts aber das beruhigt
1980 wird Blacky wegen fahrlässiger
Tötung zu 10 Jahren Haft verurteilt sein
komplettes weh bekommt 15 Jahre wegen
Totschlags
der Straftäter milling verliert dabei
mehr als seine Freiheit Blacky und sein
bester Freund Wolfgang gehen fortan
getrennte Wege das Verbrechen besiegelt
das endgültige Ende ihrer jahrelangen
Freundschaft Wolfgang kann ihm diesen
tödlichen Vorfall nicht verzeihen
[Musik]
und dann war es nachher wenn man merkt
man das so
dass er zu hören gerufen war was aber
sollte das höhere sein Blacky arbeitet
im Knast an seinen neuen Karriere mit
knapp 40 Jahren kommt der 1989 frei im
Gefängnis hatte er Engel Kontakte zur
holländischen Kokain Mafia geknüpft sein
erstes Drogengeschäft lässt nicht lange
auf sich warten als Tourist getan steigt
am 10 August 1989 in ein Flugzeug in
seinem Koffer über 10.000 D-Mark
[Musik]
von Hamburg aus geht es auf die
8191 Kilometer entfernte Karibikinsel
kudasao die kleine Insel mit 200.000
Einwohnern auf Höhe benezuelas ist
koloniales Erbe und gehört heute noch
zur niederländischen Krone damals wie
heute das Einkaufsparadies für koksieler
der erste Deal den wir in der Karibik
gemacht haben das war so stimmt
heute immer noch drüber also wir sind
darüber geflogen werden zwar in Kontakt
den habe ich gehe gestellt dass wir was
kaufen konnten so und dann haben wir
zwei Kilo gekauft sondern saßen wir im
Hotel die zwei Kilo lagen auf dem Tisch
und wir haben mit ein bisschen Whisky
gefeiert und haben schon den den wieder
mal sagen den Gewinn gefeiert und
irgendwann das vor kurzem Abflug viel
uns ein ja wir müssen das ja auch noch
rüberbringen das muss ja irgendwie auch
nach Deutschland so wir hätten gar
keinen Plan wir haben null Plan ja so
und irgendwann sagte eine ach pass auf
ich habe das in die Socken rein und
schmeiße so ein Koffer
[Musik]
vor dem ersten Transport für alle
geschwitzt und der das im Kopf hat am
meisten geschwitzt aber wir waren ja
alle noch ein bisschen besoffen deswegen
haben wir es nicht so mitgekriegt so und
dann sind wir durch durch den ersten
Zoll durch das war ein Curacao das war
so durch sondern saßen mit dem Flieger
arbeiten in Deutschland wurden wir ja
alle wieder nüchtern so und dann haben
wir überlegt wie kriegen das jetzt durch
ja mit nichts anderes möglich als äh
probieren und das ging durch das war ein
riesiges Gefühl man man hat einfach
sagen ja man hat irgendwas erreicht das
ist sowas das kann man eigentlich kann
man nicht beschreiben das einfach nur
Glücksgefühle
für seine ersten zwei Kilo Kokain hatte
Blacky in der Karibik 9000 D-Mark
bezahlt in Deutschland verkaufte das
Kram für 80 D-Mark an seine Kunden pro
Kilo machte über 50.000 DM gewinnen denn
Koks gilt damals noch als Stoff für
Insider und ist teuer seine Kunden
stammen aus der Hamburger heißes Heidi
Anfang der 90er Jahre die hatten alle
Geld die haben alle gearbeitet das war
alles das war von Ärzten über die auf
Presse Journalisten sowieso alle durch
die ballern alle
Rechtsanwälte den teilweise ich weiß
nicht was alles es gab immer Koks schon
bloß ich hatte das Beste das heißt das
war rein das war sauber wir haben nur
wir mussten das gar nicht mehr schneiden
daher wir haben das einfach so
rausgehauen wie was geholt haben
[Musik]
jetzt Geld in der Szene als der König
des Kokains vom Polizistensohn zu
Hamburgs drogende Nummer eins wow er ist
wer und niemand kann etwas beweisen
Blacky vergrößert sein Drogen Imperium
Schritt für Schritt jeder Kokain
Transport aus der Karibik wird der
karibisch geplant er lässt sogar
spezielle Koffer mit doppelten Boden
anfertigen so schaffte es in kürzester
Zeit immer größere Mengen Kokain nach
Deutschland zu schmuggeln werden
können
so viel Plätze gehabt ja und so viel
Hotels gebildet mit kurieren wir haben
teilweise auf Einschlag 70 Kilo
übergeholt
der Flieger ich hätte jeden Tag zum
Transport holen können das wird kam und
war weg
Ronald mieling macht Millionen und
genießt sein Leben in vollen Zügen
endlich ist er aus der Enge der
Mittelklasse raus er kauft sich teure
Luxuslimousinen logiert den Suiten von
edelhotels und feiert ausschweifende
Partys nur immer mit einem wachsamen
Auge gelegentlich haben das krachen
lassen ja aber nicht nicht
offensichtlich offiziell also ich bin
jetzt nicht losgelaufen und habe den
Feier Prinz gemacht habe ich bin hier
der größte das haben wir im Ausland
gemacht
auch den Behörden viel Black ist
gehobene Lebensstil langsam aber sicher
auf über den schnellen Erfolg und den
raschen Aufstieg des schneekönigs
zeigten sich selbst erfahrene
drogenermittler anfangs überrascht auch
die Hamburger Zollfahnder beschäftigten
sich damals intensiv mit dem Fall Lucky
mealin Zoll Oberinspektor Frank Nielsen
erinnert sich im Büro des Zollamts auf
dem Monitor vor ihm Scrollens ganz von
Zeitungsausschnitten der damaligen
Bericht Bestattung vorbei auf den
Bildern hat Lucky schon deutlich
zugelegt die Haare sind nicht mehr ganz
so schwarz und die Wangen deutlich
voller für Hamburg hat er halt eine
Rolle gespielt er hat sich gut verkauft
persönlich gut verkauft in den Kreisen
wo Kokain konsumiert wurde
ich glaube nicht auch nach dem was ich
von den älteren Kollegen gehört habe die
damals gegen ihn ermittelt haben dass er
eine eine wirkliche Größe gewesen ist
der Kokain Schmuggel damals war was ganz
anderes als heute damals war Kokain als
solches noch gar nicht so verbreitet
Kokain war in Anfang der 90er noch immer
so eine Schickimicki Droge die Droge da
reichen und schön aber nicht in der
breiten Masse so vertreten damals haben
wir noch sehr sehr viel mehr mit
heroinen und so weiter zu tun gehabt mit
Haschisch Marihuana deswegen hat Kokain
Schmuggel damals noch gar nicht so sehr
die Rolle gespielt und vor allen Dingen
nicht in den Größenordnung wie sie heute
vorherrschen
[Musik]
kokain ist eine aufputzdroge die meist
über die Nase aufgenommen wird ihre
Wirkung geht von Euphorie über ein
Gefühl gesteigerter Leistungsfähigkeit
hin zu Schlaf Durst und Appetitlosigkeit
beim Abklingen kann es zu einer
Depression dem Crash kommen der sich nur
mit erneutem Konsum beseitigen lässt
Folgen exzessiven Konsums sind Psychosen
Aggressivität Paranoia und physische
Schäden am Herz-Kreislauf-System und dem
Gehirn
Hauptumschlagplatz der Droge ist
Südamerika hier wird das weiße Pulver in
einem mehrstufigen Produktionsverfahren
aus den Blättern des pokerstrauchs
gewonnen von Kolumbien Peru und Bolivien
aus wird die Droge in die ganze Welt
exportiert in den ersten Jahren des
Kokain Booms Anfang der 80er Jahre
nutzen die Drogenhändler vor allem die
Karibik als Zwischenstation und
importieren ihre Ware von hier aus
weiter nach Nordamerika Anfang der 90er
Jahre beginnen die Kartelle den
europäischen Markt mit Kokain zu
überschwemmen die südamerikanischen
Drogenbarone wollen so ihre Milliarden
Gewinne weiter ausbauen gleichzeitig
verstärken die USA ihre Kontrollen die
fahrender beschlagnahmen immer größere
Mengen Kokain
die Kartelle erschließen neue
Handelsrouten mit Europa einschließlich
Deutschland finden sie schließlich einen
lukrativen Markt bis heute
Zollfahnder Nielsen in Hamburg kann die
Größenordnungen nur schätzen wie viel
Kokain wurde geschmuggeltes lässt sich
so nicht ganz einfach sagen ich kann als
Person die ich im reisefähiger eventuell
im Flieger bin in meinem Koffer was
schmuggeln und dann kann ich vielleicht
sehen oder auch 15 Kilo schmuggeln habe
ich aber einen ganzen Schiffscontainer
voll mit Ware ist es eine ganz andere
Menge da reden wir heute aktuell von
schmuggelmengen die bei 500 Kilo liegen
das kann natürlich kein einzelner
Reisender mitnehmen heute Buben der
Schmuggel und Handel mit Kokain in
Europa und Deutschland lange schon ist
das weiße Pulver keine Luxus Droge mehr
mittlerweile greifen Menschen aus allen
sozialen Schichten zum Kokain
laut dem EU Drogenbericht von 2019
konsumierten im gleichen Jahr
schätzungsweise 4,3 Millionen Europäer
das Rauschgift auch der Zoll in Hamburg
beschlagnahmt immer häufiger und immer
größere Mengen an Schmuggelware aus
Südamerika der Zoll hat letztes Jahr
2019 fast 10 Tonnen Kokain
sichergestellt in Rotterdam und
Antwerpen waren die Zahlen noch um ein
Vielfaches größer
Bremen im Sommer 2020
vollgepackt mit Einkaufstüten kommt
Lucky in einer eigens für heute
angemieteten Ferienwohnung an seine
Wohnung bleibt Privatsache Ehefrau und
Tochter warten schon eine Weile und
begrüßen den Hünen der macht sich aber
gleich an Herd und Spüle zu schaffen
die Ferienwohnung hat eine große Küche
und das ist was lucky Braut an der
langen Tafel in der Mitte des Raumes
sitzen Ines und die 17-jährige Miriam
die ein Shirt mit der Stickerei real
Gangster der Schneekönig trägt sie sich
bei stolz auf ihren Vater und gibt ihm
einen Kuss auf die Wange
schön entspannt kochende Bilder malen
das ist schön entspannt
wir haben im Knast immer gekocht und ja
irgendwann kommt immer weiter rein und
irgendwann ist alles normal
seinen Lebensmittelpunkt hat Ronald
Blacky mealing nun hier in Bremen
gefunden Miriam wuselt in der Küche
herum und hilft ihrem Vater beim Kochen
die Schülerin kennt die kriminelle
Vergangenheit ihres Vaters er hatte ihr
vor Jahren behutsam von seinen
Verbrechen berichtet was ich über die
Kokain Vergangenheit von meinem Vater
denke dass er das alles so geschafft hat
dass er nicht irgendwie weiß ich nicht
irgendwo eine Verletzung hat die ja
jetzt als Jahre später immer noch hat
sondern dass er mit 70 noch keinen
Rollator braucht noch kein Gehwagen kein
Lift um ihn um eine Treppe hoch zu
bekommen oder dass er das halt alles
noch schafft also ich glaube im Kopf ist
ja noch so ein bisschen 20 und auch beim
Thema Rauschgift Kokain wurde Miriam
nicht Ines lange dunkle Haare blaue
Augen und ein feines Lächeln um den Mund
stand ursprünglich aus Medin in
Kolumbien gelassen nimmt sie am
Mineralwasser Miriam weiß was kokain ist
wie es wird und ja was man da auch mit
anstellen kann und das ist auch eine
ganze Menge Geld bringt und sie hat von
Anfang an gesoffen ist nicht meins da
habe ich nichts mit zu tun
Vater und Tochter stehen am Herd und
verfeinern die Lauchsuppe mit Lachs der
erste Gang also ich kann mir überhaupt
nicht vorstellen dass das Miriam Kokain
im Pfeil wenn sie es will kann sie es
ich würde sie ich würde es ihr sogar
erlauben und wenn es so wäre und sie
wird mich fragen und wird sagen kannst
du mir was reines tun und so ja würde
ich machen für Miriam sind Drogen also
kein Thema das Essen ist deutlich
wichtiger
[Musik]
gut ja
für viele Jugendliche aber sind Kokain
und andere Drogen ein wichtiger
Bestandteil ihres Lebens und ihres
Selbstverständnisses als Teenager von
seiner eigenen Familie hält Blacky den
Stoff unbedingt fern in Deutschland und
da hat sich viel geändert wirklich sehr
viel seit meiner besten Zeit früher war
das eigentlich so dass
viele Deutsche das gemacht haben und das
waren alles kleine Clubs die irgendwo
ein bisschen Geduld haben heute ist das
sehr organisiert Curacao war eigentlich
Holland den warm und auf diese Insel
ging unheimlich viel ab das war ja noch
so kleinkremerei das war ein sehr viel
Arbeit für
verhältnismäßig wenig gewinnen die
schönste Zeit ist eigentlich gewesen wo
ist der Kolumbien ging also das war
Abenteuer pur zum ersten Mal erhält der
Schneekönig Zugang zu den berüchtigten
Drogenkartellen zu einer Welt der
Auftragsmorde der Korruption und der
milliardenschweren deals
Hauptstadt Kolumbiens mit 8 Millionen
Einwohnern liegt auf 2600 Metern Höhe
inmitten der Anden
slumartige Vorstädte wechseln sich mit
Hochhäusern und Kolonialbauten ab Blacky
schaut sich mit zusammengekniffenen
Augen seine selbst gefilmten alten Hai 8
Videoaufnahmen an die Fahrt durch die
quirlige Stadt des Rumpeln über
schlechte Straßen erinnert sich die
Berge und das Licht bleibt und sofort
Blitzen seine Augen wieder auf der Deal
in Kolumbien ist natürlich ein ganz
anderer wieder in Curacao in Curacao
gekauft so kleine Mengen zu 10 Kilo dann
kommen die Leute ins Hotel gefahren
bringen die mit so einer Sitze im
Hotelzimmer lieber das Licht so hin und
bezahlst du das oder was ist gut die
Kolumbianer sind eigentlich sehr saubere
Geschäft Leute und wenn du in diesem
Club drinne bist dann brauchst du dir
gar keine Gedanken machen der geht sehr
gerade aber sehr gemütlich auch wenn du
sitzt in der Familie du wirst dann
bedienen mit ein bisschen Essen bisschen
tief und Kaffee Kuchen das sehr sehr
entspannte Atmosphäre codasao ist
Geschichte jetzt will Blacky bei den
großen Jungs mitmachen und vom
Beistelltisch an die Tafel gebeten
werden ja Geschäfte mit den großen
Drogenkartellen eine nicht ganz
ungefährliche Angelegenheit von den
Leuten die jetzt in der Größenordnung
arbeiten wenn da gibt's keine
Übertragung wird da gibt's nur gerade
und tote wegen Kolumbien war ich
eigentlich ständig bewaffnet wenn ich
jetzt so irgendwelchen Freunden gegangen
bin hat man die Kanone vorne gelassen
also den hatte sie praktisch mal vorne
eine wie abgegeben so nein aber ich war
wahrscheinlich sein
[Musik]
Kokain Hochburg Kolumbien seit Anfang
der 80er Jahre boomt die Produktion und
der Handel mit der Droge zwei der
bekanntesten und mächtigsten Familien im
koksgeschäft sind das caricael unter der
Führung der Brüder Rodriguez oder und
das Medellin Kartell ihr Anführer der
berüchtigte Drogenboss Pablo Escobar bis
heute ist Kolumbien der größte Kokain
Produzent laut dem Drogenbericht der UN
von 2017 wurden dort fast 2000 Tonnen
der Droge hergestellt das entspricht 70%
des gesamten Welthandels Tendenz
steigend die Kartelle errichten dafür
Drogen Labore in den undurchdringlichen
Dschungeln von Südamerika hier
produzieren sogenannte Köche tonnenweise
reines Kokain aus den Blättern des
kokerstrauchs das Pulver wird später in
die USA aber auch weltweit verschifft
und findet seinen Weg nach Hamburg
natürlich war ich in der Kugel in Küche
ich war etliche Male da ich habe auch
oft eingekauft ich weiß nur 2 kg
schwerpasste ergeben 1 kg Kokain wenn
ich sage mal 40 50 Kilo Blätter dann
raus kriegt meine kinopaste es war nur
mal teilweise lustig die cosineros das
sind die die Köche dir nennen sie Köche
die das machen die schmecken mit den
Fingern ab die haben das äh keine Ahnung
das sind die machen das Beste Kokain ich
habe das eigentlich getestet mich nicht
mit der Nase viele testen ja mit der
Nase das habe ich nicht gemacht man kann
das Reiben zwischen den Fingern dann
spürt man weil es ist eine Schnee das
muss wie Schnee schmelzen bei den
letzten Worten reibt Lucky die
Fingerspitzen aneinander als würde ihn
wieder spüren den Stoff der seine Welt
war eine Welt die nun das höre war zudem
sein alter Freund Wolfgang Gier ihn
berufen fühlte
Ortswechsel Hamburger Hafen Lucky sitzt
bei Bier und Fischbrötchen auf der
Aussichtsplattform und schaut dem
Treiben auf dem Wasser zu nun fällt sein
Blick auf ein riesiges Containerschiff
wenn man mich fragt wie will John mich
hier eingeführt habe dann werde ich das
natürlich nicht beantworten und ich kann
euch dazu sagen ja es war ein bisschen
was ja wenn ich hier bin und
Containerschiffe sie kriegen immer
feuchte Hände und feuchte Hände waren
bei mir immer große mein Geld gekommen
Ronald Mehling war und ist mit
Sicherheit nicht der einzige der genau
in diesem Moment feuchte Hände bekommt
neben Rotterdam und Antwerpen zählt der
Hamburger Hafen heute als
Hauptumschlagplatz für Kokain in Europa
experten vermuten dass hier jährlich
hunderte Tonnen Kokain in Containern
versteckt werden doch das Zoll
fahndungsamt der Hansestadt kennt heute
viele Tricks der südamerikanischen
Schmuggler alleine 2019 konnten die
Ermittler bei Kontrollen fast 10 Tonnen
Kokain sicherstellen viel aber
vermutlich ein Tropfen auf dem heißen
Stein
zurück zu Zoll Oberinspektor Niesen
wieder rufte auf seinem Rechner Fotos
von drogenfunden auf Koffer Tüten
katzenfuttersäcke es gibt grundsätzlich
zwei Arten Drogen zu schmuggeln zwei
große Verfahren haben die immer wieder
auftauchen das ist dieses drop off und
das ist zum Beispiel eine Geschichte da
ist im rip-off-verfahren dabei zeigte
ein Foto von einem geöffneten Container
drinnen viele Sporttaschen und ein
schicker Oldtimer das waren damals 190
Kilogramm die in diesen berühmten
Sporttaschen direkt hinter der Tür des
Containers liegen legal waren zwei
Oldtimer VW Busse T1 Modelle wir haben
die Türen aufgemacht und stand direkt
vor den Taschen mit dem Kokain das ist
dieses Jahr gewesen das nächste Foto
zeigt dutzende riesige wasserdichte
Rucksäcke hinter einem stahldurchgang zu
einem Hohlraum von Wohnzimmer Größe ein
Schiff wo wir dann bei einer
Durchsuchung in einem großen
begehbaren Teil des Schornsteins vom
Schiffe vom Schiff hinter einem Mann
Loch 500 Kilo Kokain gefunden haben das
war für das sogenannte
drop-off-verfahren präpariert das heißt
die Seefest wasserfesten Taschen sollten
über Bord geschmissen werden das
wiederum bedeutet aber immer dass jemand
von der Kuh auch involviert ist weil es
muss ja jemand an Bord die Taschen über
Bord schmeißen jede Fund im Hamburger
Hafen wird vom Zollfahndungsamt in
laborener kribbisch geprüft und chemisch
analysiert so sammelt die Behörde
wichtige Erkenntnisse über Qualität und
Marktwert der Droge das Kokain wie ist
aus Südamerika kommt wenn es nicht
gestreckt es liegt um bei 90 bis 95%
Reinheitsgehalt wie rechnen hier im
Prinzip für Hamburg mit um bei 50.000 €
für Kilo
der Hamburger Zoll leistet seinen
Beitrag denn laut dem aktuellen
Drogenbericht der Vereinten Nationen
wurden im Jahr 2017 weltweit
1.275 Tonnen Kokain abgefangen im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr eine Steigerung um
13 Prozent vermutlich fallen die Zahlen
für 2020 noch höher aus
[Musik]
Bogota Mitte der 90er Lucky und Partner
Rumpel mal wieder mit dem Jeep fröhlich
durch die börsenvolle Stadt sie pfeifen
den jungen Frauen hinterher lucky ist
jetzt nicht mehr ganz so jung und
knackig aber er versprüht Charme und
Vitalität die Vororte von Bogota sind
dann wenig später auf der Fahrt nicht
mehr ganz so schick aus große
Schlaglöcher wilde Stromkabel
Prostitution und Drogenhandel
Kolumbien wird Blackys zweite Heimat er
verbringt dort nun mehrere Monate im
Jahr der 43-Jährige pflegt seinen neuen
Geschäftsbeziehungen sorgfältig und baut
ein perfektstrukturiertes Netzwerk aus
Ronald mieling befindet sich auf dem
Höhepunkt seiner diele-karriere und er
schafft es in die strengen
abgeschotteten Kreise der Kartelle
aufgenommen zu werden
das ist eher so eine Ehrbezeugung dass
du oder dass du hier Boss bist ne es
gibt nicht nur paar blödes globalen in
Kolumbien es gibt noch ganz andere Clubs
ich habe noch nie getroffen ich hätte
aber können
die Kolumbianer machen Blacky ein
Angebot er soll neue Transportwege für
die Kartelle Ausprobieren von Polen nach
Deutschland es geht um 2 Tonnen Koks
Luckys Anteil 250 Kilo sein Gewinn 15
Millionen D-Mark heute 7,5 Millionen
Euro der Polier war so wir haben mit
vier Leuten zusammengeschmissen also in
Kolumbien das macht man oft da dass man
so und so ein Pool macht so jeder 500
Kilo der Weg ging nach Polen nach Danzig
und von Danzig aus so einem Binnenschiff
praktisch nach Deutschland gehen das war
alles geregelt und da ist eigentlich
folgendes passiert die haben das geklaut
die Polen wollen auf eigene Rechnung
arbeiten sie fangen das Kokain ab bevor
es nach Deutschland verschifft werden
kann für Blacky dem Schneekönig eine
lebensgefährliche Situation Platz der
polen-deal käme das seinem Todesurteil
gleich Blacky wischt sich über die
weißen stoppelhaare auf seinem Kopf und
sein Blick verfinstert sich
keine zweite Chance sondern wenn du
etwas Gravierendes gemacht hast dann
reagieren die und das allgemein bekannte
die hängen die Leute an den Füßen auf
und Sonnen Baum und dann werden die in
Schwung gebracht Schaukeln in unseren
Waffel du triffst ja gar nicht das ist
sehr schwierig jemand zu treffen so auf
50 Meter zu unterballern
[Musik]
ja die Kolumbianer sind außer sich vor
Wut und der massiven Drohungen fordern
sie von den Dieben die sofortige
Herausgabe der Ware die polenwilligen
irgendwann aus Angst ein
bleiki soll jetzt die erneute Übergabe
organisieren er ist der Mann für
schwierige Situationen die Kolumbianer
vertrauen ihm doch der Deal entwickelt
sich für den Schneekönig zu einem
Desaster ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht
in die Nähe von diesem Kokain kommen so
und dann haben wir uns die Polen auf der
Straße glaube ich keine Ahnung 130 Kilo
übergeben so das war für mich vom
chaotisch dann habe ich die bei dem bei
den Transporteur ins Auto packen lassen
und bin dann sind wir nach der Stettin
geworden
ihr bleibt hier macht gar nichts sondern
das einzige was ihr macht hier ein
Leihwagen kaufen
das ein und
kann Fahrzeug da steht den Schlüssel
stecken auf dem Markt
brauchen die nicht
so das war der Plan sondern will ich
nach Deutschland gefahren und ich habe
sofort gemerkt die diese
[Musik]
Frau von diesem von diesen Transporteur
zu Dir habe ich gesagt Mädel nicht
anrufen nicht dies nicht das und dann
passiert der folgendes eine geburtstag
und sie nimmt das Telefon ihr
Haustelefon ruf den an herzlichen
Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag mein Schatz
so eine ganze vorstellen dann knallt der
Polizeipräsidium Direktor und dann kam
die Bullen sind da eingeflogen haben den
anderen mit dem Auto und den Kofferraum
erwischt und dann haben sie falsche
natürlich gewusst weil sie mich eine
Verbindung gesehen haben und ich wusste
jetzt bin ich als nächstes dran ne das
geht also schief mieling muss irgendwie
handeln die Polizei nimmt sofort die
drei Kuriere in Polen Fest eine von
ihnen packt über Blacky und seine
Geschäfte mit den Kolumbianern aus der
Schneekönig kann gerade noch so nach
Hamburg fliegen er weiß dass er im
Visier der Polizei steht und jetzt rund
um die Uhr beschattet und abgehört wird
Ortswechsel Hamburg Lucky fährt mit
seinem unscheinbaren C-Klasse Benz auf
der alten Fluchtroute beschauliche
Wohngebiete lösen breitere Straßen ab
wir sind ihre Jahre Straße und ich muss
sagen ich habe wieder ein bisschen
Adrenalin weil das war meine
fruchtstrecke dann bin ich wenn ich mich
nicht täusche ja genau hier abgebogen
natürlich nicht so lahmarschig wie heute
sondern schon mit Schmackes ich habe
einen Ketchup im Auto gehabt und konnte
ihre Telefon abhören
Mainz abgehört ich habe erst abgehört
wenn die sich unbeobachtet fühlen
wollten dann haben sie gesagt dann gehen
wir mal auf das kleine das Kleine war
immer ein Handy und damals gab es sie
nicht und ihr seht das habe ich abgehört
wo ich da oben an der Straße war habe
ich hier habe ich über ihre Telefone
gehört wie die Zugriff planen so und bei
Zugriff habe ich Gas gegeben und diese
Ampel habe ich überquert bin ungefähr
weiß das nicht aber 220 230 bin ich hier
rübergehogelt und wenn man jetzt wenn
man jetzt über diese Straße fährt diese
dann ist das so ein leichtes rüber so
ein leichter Hügel und ich bin damals
direkt über die Kreuzung geflogen das
Auto hat abgehoben wenn man sich eine
Verhaftungen ziehen will dann kann man
nicht überlegen ob man Verkehrsregeln
einhält und dann kann man auch nicht
überlegen wie gefährlich das ist da muss
man Gas geben
von entweder klappt das oder klappt das
nicht und wenn das nicht klappt ja gut
dann landet vielleicht im Rollstuhl
Alter
Blacky hat Glück kein Unfall keine
anderen Menschen kommen zu schaden und
er entkommt die Flucht gelingt doch
blacky ist noch lange nicht außer
gefahren er muss sich einen Plan B
überlegen
noch zwei oder drei Monate drei Monate
in Hamburg dann habe ich ein bisschen
gekauft und hat mich vom Freund von mir
fahren lassen
[Musik]
was er nicht ahnt deutsche Zielfahnder
sind ihm auf den Fersen observieren ihn
auf dem Flughafen von San Antonio in
Venezuela endet schließlich die Flucht
des kokain-königs Lucky wird
festgenommen
und dann haben sie erst mal mich auf
seine Wache gebracht und dann musste ich
praktisch mich röntgen lassen auf
Toilette gehen weil ich dachte ich
Schmuggel haben sie meine Koffer
durchsucht aber nichts drin aber alles
normal und dann habe ich bisschen
telefoniert gemacht getan und dann kam
der irgendwann an und hat gesagt wir
hätten Angebote für dich der die Akten
angeguckt und und und hat er gesagt okay
es hätten
[Musik]
Angeboten preisgeben ein verlockendes
Angebot Blacky muss eine Entscheidung
treffen ich habe darüber nachgedacht und
habe mir gedacht okay was passiert dir
wenn du das machst du gehst darüber die
Pressen dich aus sie setzen dich ein das
bringt dir gar nichts weil irgendwann
fängt so eine Kugel und für was damit
die britisch wieder Informationen haben
so was passiert in Deutschland gut in
Deutschland 15 Jahre denn zwei Drittel
sind möglich sind Haare schon was auch
möglich ist fuhren offene Vollzug also
das heißt acht Jahre Knast maximal 8
Jahre Knast auch das schaffst du
eine harte Entscheidung statt in
Freiheit als V-Mann für die
us-drogenfahndung zu leben wählt plaki
das deutsche Gefängnis zwölf Jahre
harter Knastalltag aber von Reue keine
Spur war es die richtige Entscheidung
was die Liebe zu seiner Freundin oder
die Liebe zu Hamburg jedenfalls ist die
JVA Fuhlsbüttel in Hamburg kurz Santa Fu
sein neues zu Hause das schillernde
Leben des schneekönigs ist damit vor es
zu Ende und man nimmt sich den
Schneekönig erst einmal richtig zur
Brust dem wird man das Geschäft schon
austreiben
[Musik]
darf man mich praktisch in Israel das
heißt links und rechts die Zellen sind
nicht belegt du hast den doppelte
Fenster du hast wieder mal sagen noch
Plastik vorm Fernseher da kommt gar
keine Luft rein du schwitzt sich der Tod
da drinne und du kannst nicht mit ein
knackig sprechen das heißt du bist
völlig isoliert deine Freistunde machst
du mit dem Beamten
Einkauf machst du alleine
der Duschen alleine alles alleine das
heißt du wirst wieder mal geistig
getötet also habe ich praktisch mit
meinem Fernseher gesprochen und der
Fernseher war mein unterhaltungspartner
die Isolationshaft setzt Lucky zu
erhaltet und die schwarzen Haare waren
einmal nach zwei Jahren kommt der
schließlich in den normalen Vollzug
morgen vor aufstehen um glaube ich 6 Uhr
so und dann wird aufgestanden aber die
Tür auf und von Abend um 7:30 Uhr sind
die Tür wieder zugegangen aber was in
der Zwischenzeit gemacht
Leute besuchen du konntest
frei bewegen das war die Freiheit hier
im Knast in frei nach außen sicher und
da wohnen sondern ich musste mich hier
wohl fühlen weil anders wäre es nicht
gegangen
für die Hamburger Behörden und Frank
Nielsen vom Zoll war die Verhaftung des
schneekönigs ein Erfolg das war schon
ein großer Fall damals der Damen und
abgeschlossen wurde weil wir
damals schon in einem Bereich mit Medien
gewesen sind der halt
organisiert Kokain aus Südamerika nach
Deutschland gebracht hat da ging es ja
damals wirklich um 100 Kilo das war für
damalige Verhältnisse schon sehr sehr
viel im knastland Lucky auch andere
kriminelle größten kennen er Freunde
sich z.B auch mit Mike Wappler an alias
Milliarden Mike ein Bekannter Hamburger
Betrüger der sich durch dubiose
Geschäfte Millionen ergaunete aber das
ist nicht das Geschäftsmodell von Ronald
Mehling er bleibt bei seinen Leisten die
Strukturen die ein Übersee aufgebaut hat
hält er für stabil ich habe ihn noch
einen guten Namen und ich kann jederzeit
darüber fahren und ich würde immer sehr
freundlich empfangen werden immerhin hat
er nie jemanden verpfiffen und so träumt
Lucky auch während seiner Haft in seiner
Fuß von Bogota dort schmiedet der große
Pläne er will wieder mit den
kolumbianischen Kartellen ins Geschäft
kommen koste es was es wollen
im Dezember 2003 wird Blacky der
mittlerweile 53 Jahre alt ist vorzeitig
aus dem Gefängnis entlassen seine
Reststrafe ist auf Bewährung ausgesetzt
doch statt sein Leben nun neu zu ordnen
setzte sich in den nächsten Flieger Ziel
Kolumbien der nächste Millionen Deal
wartet ich hatte damals
schon mit jemand kann man sagen wird in
Kolumbianer der hat mich gebeten seine
Truppe in Amsterdam praktisch
einzuordnen das heißt
ja einmal Kunden die die ja immer noch
hatte und wie die sich in Europa bewegen
sollen also ich sollte die praktisch
einordnen oder soll ich trainieren und
dafür jetzt eine Million Dollar gegeben
eine Million Dollar ein recht guter Lohn
für eine Beratertätigkeit sollte man
annehmen aber sein Ruf als gewiefter
Gauner weckt größere Begehrlichkeiten
die großen kolumbianischen Bosse wollen
das Blacky in Ihrem Land selbst als
Schmuggler in Erscheinung tritt und ich
war gar nicht vor gehabt was zu machen
war überhaupt nicht geplant 60 Kilo oder
sowas irgendsowas also einen kleinen
Transporter so und ich hätte das
praktisch hier gemanagt dass das
rausgeholt wird und praktisch jemand
gleich gegeben oder wäre es weg gewesen
ne das war das war dilettantisch dumm
gewesen auch der die Ausführung von den
Eltern Tisch und ich habe versucht das
irgendwie von der Backe zu kriegen aber
ich bin da nicht vorweg gekommen gut
Künstler wenn man irgendwas zusagt muss
man sagen Lucky hatte sich in seinem
eigenen Netz verfangen die schlecht
geplante Aktion bleibt auch von den
deutschen Behörden nicht unbemerkt
wieder sind sie Blacky auf den Fersen
beobachten jeden seiner Schritte das
kokain-geschäft des schneekönigs wird
minusius protokolliert er kann sich kaum
irgendwo blicken lassen und muss alles
aus der Ferne organisieren Material und
Crew sind diesmal auch nicht die erste
Wahl und natürlich zwei Leute die habe
ich einfach beauftragt gehabt
irgendwohin zu fahren und das vom Schiff
zu holen
warum habt ihr den gesagt nicht
telefonieren und wenn ihr da ankommt und
die sollten sich Arbeitsklamotten
anziehen wie die ganzen Seeleute da
anhaben und auf einfach auf Schiff
raufgehen die wussten wo das ist und das
rausholen und wenn ihr das Gefühl habt
dass jemand euch Bescheid oder so dann
lass das liegen konnte nach Hause
sondern passierte folgendes dann gab es
ein Telefonat ja ich glaube wir werden
verfolgt
wollte gar nicht warum verfolgen die
euch eigentlich ja wir sind doch jetzt
im Hafen dieser was für ein Hafen denn
ich habe mich völlig blöd gestellt aber
nichts im Hafen von Antwerpen Platz der
Deal die belgischen Drogenfahnder
beschlagnahmen in einem Überseecontainer
11 Kilo Kokain blakisiere werden noch
vor Ort festgenommen
im November 2005 knapp zwei Jahre nach
seiner Haft Entlassung stürmen schwer
bewaffnete sek Beamte mehlingswohnung in
Hamburg und nehme ihn erneut fest
Bremen Blacky steht wieder am Herd für
das birth Stroganoff den zweiten Gang
und das Lieblingsessen der Tochter
Miriam Ehefrau Ines beobachtet ihn bei
seiner Arbeit belustigt muss Ronald
mähling kurz auf Lachen das Messer fährt
dabei in das marmorierte Fleisch diese
Szene hatte ich schon mal bei der
letzten Verhaftung da war das ein
Schweinebraten und ich war gerade dabei
mit dieser Fleischgabel und dem Messer
deine Scheibe abzuschneiden ich wollte
gerade rein piepsen und dann hat das mit
geklopft wieder Ramme
sind die Polizisten gekommen
Einsatzkommando und ich bin auf dem Flur
gegangen und war natürlich erstaunt wenn
er klopft dann flog die Tür auf und
Luftfahrt vier fünf sechs Leute ich weiß
nicht mehr wie viel die sprengen da rein
und da natürlich mich mit dem Messer und
der fleischkabel aber ich war ja zu
Hause und ich mein Schatz und in den
T-Shirt und das sprengend direkt wieder
raus und sagten legen Sie die Waffen weg
und ich meine cool drauf hab gesagt die
mensch Jungs
das sind keine Waffen ich will mein
[Musik]
Schweine das tut weh gut dann habe ich
das weggelegt und dann haben sie mich
halt mit allem Mann überwältigt weil ich
stand da und ich ja gut
Blacky geht erneut ins Gefängnis diesmal
für zehn Jahre diese Inhaftierung ist
für ihn besonders bitter denn auch im
Privatleben des schneekönigs hat sich
einiges verändert
und hier sitzt die Veränderung in
persona am Küchentisch Blacky und seine
langjährige Freundin Ines trafen sich
damals in seiner knastzeit schon seit
zwei Jahren regelmäßig und dann kommt
bald Tochter Miriam zur Welt
kennengelernt haben wir uns Anfang der
80er Jahre in einer aufdisco in der
Verlauf dieser Beziehung ist immer
konstant gewesen der Kontakt bestimmt
immer aber manchmal treffen etwas
dürftig aus weil er auf ihn unterwegs
war aber Kontakt bestand immer das hat
es wohl von Anfang an hat die heute
60-Jährige Blackys kriminelle Karriere
miterlebt bei seinen Kokain Deals hat
sie sich jedoch immer rausgehalten
bleibt die macht einen zufriedenen
Eindruck er ser viert das gibt ein
privates Leben das ist meins und das
Geschäftliche da habe ich nichts drin zu
suchen gehabt und das wollte ich auch ja
und 2018 machen Blacky und Ines ihre
Liebe endgültig offiziell und heiraten
[Musik]
das heißt sehr guten oder schlechten
Zeiten und über die ganzen Jahre weil
sie hat ihren Weg gemacht weil sie
hätten so lieben wie ich gemacht so
Freunde ich habe kriminellen Weg gemacht
das passt ja nicht um zusammen zu leben
aber jetzt im Alter passt doch ich habe
meinen kriminellweg abgelegt in dieser
Woche ihren Weg oder sich dann mit allen
Dellen oder wieso alte Auto
tja
aber nur Spuren im Leben machen
2016 zwei Jahre vor der Hochzeit kam
Blacky frei insgesamt saß er 32,5 Jahre
lang fast die Hälfte seines Lebens in
deutschen Gefängnissen seine letzten
Haftjahre hatte in der JVA glasmoor in
Hamburg verbracht heute wohnt der
ehemalige Schneekönig mit seiner Familie
eher bürgerlich und konservativ ein
Leben das er früher verabscheute eine
Dreizimmerwohnung statt Hotels mieten
600 € monatliche Rente statt Bündel
voller hundert Euroscheine vom
schillernden Gangster zum braven
Familienvater aber bleib wie sieht das
locker und es läuft gut für ihn ich
kriege aufstock ich Rente und Stock die
auf ja alle alle denken irgendwo habe
ich noch Millionen Verstecke das
versuchen die alle Nachrichten auch
[Musik]
Ortswechsel Hamburger Hafen auch ohne
Blacky das Milliardengeschäft mit Kokain
boomt weiter alleine 2019 hat der
Schmuggel mit dem weißen Pulver einen
neuen Rekordwerte erreicht laut Experten
liegt die weltweite Nachfrage nach
Kokain bei schätzungsweise etwa 900
Tonnen pro Jahr mehr als 18 Millionen
Menschen konsumieren regelmäßig das
weiße Pulver so der aktuelle
drogenberichte Vereinten Nationen Ronald
Mehling schürzt die Lippen und zuckt mit
den Schultern die ganze Welt ein Problem
die ganze Welt hat Drogenprobleme und
die ganze Welt denkt wenn sie die
Polizei Maßnahme erhöhen dann irgendwann
gewinnen sie nein die haben schon lange
verloren zu legalisieren wird der
schlauste Schritt in die Politik machen
könnte die gehen nach Prophet ist groß
nach Schätzungen von Experten werden
jährlich 90 Milliarden US-Dollar mit
Kokain umgesetzt die internationalen
Drogenkartelle wollen ihre Gewinnmargen
weiter steigern dafür mindern sie die
Qualität des Kokains das ist nichts für
den Schneekönig der unbewusst schon
wieder die Fingerspitzen aneinander
reibt und auf die großen Schiffe im
Hafen schaut ich habe damals noch immer
über 90 Prozent gehabt aber wenn ich
meine schlechte Sorte hat er das 88
gehabt aber sonst immer ist über 90 weit
über 90 sogar heute kann man sagen hat
dass wenn das gut ist hat das 85
meistens nur 75 das heißt der Gewinn ist
äh Dumme ist erhöht
ja da sind Abführmittel drinne da sind
der
Entwurmungsmittel für Hunde drin ich
weiß nicht was die da alles reinstecken
also das was was du dazu dir nimmst das
ist das schädlicher Jahrzehnte lang
Knast Entbehrungen und familiäre
Schicksalsschläge hat Mehling aus seinen
Fehlern gelernt oder juckt ihn das
schmutzige immer noch
Lucky schmunzelt die Frage habe ich
heute wieder einsteigen könnte
kann man mit ganz kleinen Jahr
beantworten wenn nicht wollte weil du
kannst zum Beispiel als fassadenkletter
als Einbrecher da musst du mit 30
aufhören weil da bist du nicht mehr fit
genug im kokain-handel oder überhaupt im
drogenhandeln ist egal wie alt du bist
du musst die Kontakte haben und du musst
den Kopf haben und du musst die Leute
haben die sich akzeptieren kommt viel
zusammen das ganze machen vom Rollstuhl
aus
da brauchst du nicht richtig jung sein
für
[Musik]
ich werde Schläger nicht bleiben
nächstes Mal tauchen wir einen die Welt
der verbrecher-clans mit ihrer
Geschichte ihren Hierarchien und ihren
Millionen Kurs verpasse keine Folge und
abonniere Tatort Deutschland
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild produziert von den Wake world
Studios Projektleitung Lutz Neumann und
Simone terrak Produktion Fabian
Scheffler und Felix stehlein
Bildredaktion Kristin Wahl Frank
Schneider und Stefan Netzeband Sprecher